الصين تقيل مسؤولا بارزا وتحمله مسؤوليه
انحراف المنطاد رئيس وزراء اسرائيلي يكشف
وعدا من بوتين
مصريه تعيش بجوار قبور ابنائها منذ 33
عاما تروي قصتها للعربيه هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا
بكم
في اخر المستجدات حول قضيه المنطاد الصيني
اعلنت بكيل اقاله رئيس هيئه الارصاد
الجويه في البلاد محمله اياه مسؤوليه
انحراف المنطاد الى امريكا كان طائره
مقاتله عسكريه امريكيه اسقطت ما يشتبه
بانه من قاضي تجسس صيني اثناء تحليقه
قباله ساحل ولايه الجنوبيه في نهايه
الدراميه سلطت الضوء على تدهور العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه في المقابل انتقدت بكين
واشنطن لاسقاطها المنطاد وصفه الخطوه
بانها مبالغه واضحه في رد الفعل اما وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه فاعتبرت ان الصين
استخدمت المنطاد في محاوله مراقبه مواقع
استراتيجيه في الولايات المتحده
في خبر اثر ضجه واسعه في وسائل الاعلام
ومواقع التواصل كشف رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي سابق نفتالي انه اخذ وعدا من
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بعدم قتل
نظيره
الاوكرانيت التي قام بواسطه لفتره وجيزه
في بدايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قال
انه سال بوتين عما اذا كان ينوي قتلىنسكي
ليجيب زعيم الكرملين لن اقتله مضيفا انه
قال له يجب ان تعدني بانك لن تقتل
زيلينسكي فاجاب لن اقتل كما ذكر بانيت انه
اتصل هاتفيا بالرئيس الاوكراني بعد ذلك
لابلاغه بوعدي بوتين له
والى مصر هذه المره حيث تفاعل رواد مواقع
التواصل مع قصه مؤلمه لسيده تعيش بجوار
قبور ابنائها منذ الثلاثه وثلاثين عاما في
مدينه بني سويف جنوب البلاد الام المكلومه
ناديه عبد الحميد تقول للعربيه انها تقضي
يومها بالكامل في المقابر بجوار مرقد
ابنائها الاربعه ثم تذهب فقط للنوم في
منزلها وتعود صباح اليوم التالي مشيره الى
انها تتحدث يوميا مع ابنائها وكانهم ما
زالوا احياء وتروي لهم تفاصيل حياتها
اليوميه وكانهم يسمعونها واضافت سيده انها
فقدت ابنائها الاربعه في حريق نشب بمنزلها
اثرانفجار اسطوانه غاز في العام 1990
بعدما اشترت للمره الاولى في حياتها تذكره
يا نصيب فاز الطالبه كنديه تبلغ من العمر
18 عاما بالجائزه الكبرى البالغه 48 مليون
دولار لتصبح بذلك اصغر شخص يفوز في كندا
بمبلغ كبير كهذا وخلال تسلمها الجائزه
اوضحت لامور انها اشترت اول تذكره يانصيب
بعدما شجعها جدها على ذلك مشيره الى انها
لم تتابع نتائج السحب ولم يخطر في بالها
انها قد تكون الفائزه قبل ان يخبرها
زملائها بانها صاحبه التذكره الفائزه
وقالت الفتاه ان والدها سيساعدها في
استثمار جائزها الضخمه
وفي خبرنا الاخير تعرض رجل امريكي لموقف
محرج وطريف بالوقت نفسه حينما تلقى فاتوره
بقيمه الف دولار بعدما طلب طفله مجموعه
متنوعه من الطعام في نهايه الاسبوع صحيفه
التي نشرت الخبر اوضحت ان الرجل تفاجا
بتراكم الطعام بسرعه عند عتبه منزله
ليتبين لاحقا ان الامر حدث عندما سمح
لابنه البالغ من العمر 6 سنوات باستخدام
هاتفه المحمول ليلعب لعبه قبل النوم مشيرا
الى ان الاب او مشيره اي صحيفه الى ان
الابا قال ان ابنه طلب الطعام من العديد
من الاماكن المختلفه لدرجه ان المصرف ارسل
له تنبيها بالاحتيال